actualité puisque l'assemblée entame
aujourd'hui l'examen du budget de la
Sécurité sociale parmi les mesures
possibles la mise à contribution de
l'agir carcos c'est la caisse de
retraite du privé pour participer à
l'équilibre du régime de retraite vous y
êtes opposé vous et les partenaires
sociaux pour le moment la mesure ne
figure pas dans le texte est-ce que vous
avez l'espoir que le gouvernement y
renonce absolument oui oui je pense
qu'on a su fait on a fait preuve de de
de responsabilité organisation syndicale
et patronale on a conclu un accord avec
du plus pour les retraités 13 millions
de retraités qui bénéficient de la
retraite complémentaire une
revalorisation à hauteur de 4,9 % de la
de la pension euh la fin d'un malus le
la question de la possibilité d'avoir du
cumul emploi retraite enfin voilà ça
fait partie de la de la c'était ça
faisait partie de la donne de départ de
cette négociation on a rempli on a voilà
ça ve dire vous êtes sûr que le
gouvernement ne reviendra pas sur cette
mesure alors ça ça fait partie des des
inconnus voilà donc on a eu le temps de
de discuter aussi avec le gouvern
ouvernement après la conclusion de
l'accord et donc on a expliqué aussi en
quoi on était opposé à cette à cette
ponction donc on attend voilà la
décision mais vous attendez qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce que vous faites si parce que
le gouvernement par voie d'amendement
peut encoreoduire cette ption quelle
sera votre réaction si c'est le cas bah
on réagira on verra je pense que déjà il
faudra qu'on qu'on se coordonne entre
signatair de l'accord puisque ça a fait
l'objet des discussions pendant la
négociation au au global on avait nous
ouvert un peu la porte en disant bon
s'il doit y avoir soutien du régime
complémentaire à la mesure notamment
pour le les basses pensions du régime
général on est prêt à regarder le
gouvernement a été intransigent on n'a
pas
souhaité regarder le montant avec nous
donc donc on en discutera entre entre
signataires de de quelle sera la
meilleure voilà la même la meilleure
position la meilleure stratégie ça sera
quand même un sacré contresignal d'un
gouvernement qui nous explique depuis le
mois de juillet qu'il change de méthode
qu' veulent du dialogue avec les
organisations syndicales et patronnales
et qui et qui
veulent que chacun prenne sa place et
ses responsabilité je pense qu'on a pris
notre place on est en responsabilité
avec cet accord donc ce sera quo un de
respect pour vous ça serait ça serait ça
serait juste du discours et et là
l'illustration par les actes que l'on
souhaite que le gouvernement ne pratique
pas cette fonction dans le casadre du
PFS